what we're going to try and do is look
under the bonnet of the government with
the former head of the civil service to
see what kind of shape
the machine's in but first let's remind
ourselves what
dominic cummings actually had to say on
wednesday
the truth is that senior ministers
senior officials senior advisers like me
fell disastrously short of the standards
that the public has a right to expect
of its government in a crisis like this
when the public needed us most the
government failed tens of thousands of
people
died who didn't need to die the
government rhetoric was we put a shield
around care homes and blah blah
it was complete nonsense quite the
opposite of putting a shield around them
we sent people with covert back to the
care homes
the secretary of state for health should
have been fired
for at least 15 20 things including
lying to everybody
in multiple occasions in meeting after
meeting in the in the cabinet room and
publicly
the view of various officials inside
number 10 was
if we have the prime minister chair in
cobra meetings and he just tells
everyone
it's swine flu don't worry about it i'm
going to get chris witty to inject me
live on tv with coronavirus so everyone
realizes
it's nothing to be frightened of that
would be
that would not help actually serious
planning you guys in the political
parties need to ask yourselves
what is it about your parties that give
choices like
johnson versus corbett and we have to
ask what is it about whitehall
that promotes so many senior people who
are completely out of their depth
there is no plan we're in huge trouble
i've come through here to the telemache
morris said i've come through here to
the prime minister's office to tell you
all
quote i think we are absolutely
lord curse lake bob kurzlek was head of
the civil service for three years to
2014
having spent more than a decade as chief
executive of sheffield city council
in recent years though he himself sits
as a cross bench peer
he's advised the labour party and what
it needs to do to prepare
for government bob kerslake what is it
about whitehall did you get any answers
uh from dominic cummings testimony did
you learn
anything that you didn't already know
well look i've been a vocal critic of
dominic cummings and some of the things
he said but i have to say we learned a
lot
on wednesday and we should in a sense be
grateful that we've had this early
indication
of just how things actually worked uh
behind
the number 10 door and there were i said
i'm afraid some serious failings that
have to be recognized
the focus has been on the political
failings but there are also lessons to
be learned
for the civil service and indeed for the
whole of the government machine
as well i'm a great supporter of much of
what the civil service does there are
some very able people there
but if we don't learn then there's a
real risk
and this is a point in the coming made
that we're simply ill prepared for the
next time we face
this kind of crisis so yes there are
some serious lessons to be learned here
about
our preparations about how we
listened and learned the experiences
from other countries
about the pace of which we did things
and crucially about the
openness with which we communicated with
the public
so yes definitely there's something to
learn here
is it thank you this is this is very
interesting this these issues of pace
and
openness were in a sense illuminated by
an example that he and other people
have quoted which is that the great
success
of the government during the pandemic
whatever its other mistakes
has been the vaccine program and that
was
delivered by a task force recruited
largely from outside whitehall operating
to rules that are not unknown but quite
uncommon within whitehall
is that the way you saw it and do you
think that we don't have to go abroad
can we learn lessons from
that experience i think we can it's fine
to bring in outside people
at the right point at the right time but
of course they work with the civil
service and crucially in this instance
work with the nhs we talk about
the success of the task force but what
about the success of our nhs
in organizing and delivering those
vaccines
a great success and we should celebrate
that i have no reverse to bring in
people from outside
but what i think is our fundamental
challenge as a country here trevor
is our complacency in arrogance the
so-called british exceptionalism that
we're always going to be the best and we
just
need to approach the lessons learned
here with a sense of humility we have
something to learn
and something to improve and by the way
i think we should be having this inquiry
sooner rather than later i do not accept
the arguments
you know that we heard from the minister
about the delay uh
it's vitally important for the families
who were
lost loved ones or who got long covered
uh
to hear those lessons now otherwise all
we're going to get is the kind of
partial tit for tap
testimonies of cummings and others
so uh you're pretty clear really here
aren't you that
all of those people who pop up on radio
and television and say
we have this extraordinary rolls-royce
machine
that actually the problem is all to do
with the politicians and their silliness
and so on
um really need to take a good look at
their
uh the way our public services work uh
bingham
made a rather interesting example where
she said that they had to call a meeting
and um they were told that they had to
invite 285
people within the civil service to it
is that the kind of thing that you think
we need to do something about
yeah we need to be more agile no don't
get me wrong there's a lot of things
that the sales service does
extraordinarily well so
this is not an attack on the civil
service my argument against cummings was
that you don't change and improve
organizations by going to war with them
but if we want to really be the best we
have to
learn lessons uh we need to be more
agile we crucially need to be more
prepared
in 2019 we thought we were one of the
best prepared
countries in the world for a pandemic we
clearly weren't
similarly the communications has been a
major issue we weren't even
allowed to know who was on the sage
committee never mind what it was
actually
saying and doing i think there's nothing
short of a revolution needed in the way
we run this country it's about how
politicians conduct themselves
but it's also about how our public
servants do their role
as well not that often the head of civil
service calls for a revolution but i
i guess uh what you're saying is that if
we were hit
with something similar to january 2020
in january 2022
at the present in the present
configuration actually
we'd be no better off uh in coping with
it
i would have learned some lessons of
course i don't want to say there won't
be and indeed
there were lessons learned but just look
at the
uh way in which we handled the second
lockdown it felt like
uh we really had learned almost nothing
and this is the point kirsten has made
that you can just about understand how
things were in the first lockdown
but to go through it again in the second
lockdown it shows a
a paucity of of learning really so we
wouldn't be as
better placed as we need to be if we
faced another pandemic and crucially for
me
we need to be better at two things
number one
we need to be better at long-term
planning in this country
not always reacting if you'll forgive me
to the latest news story
and number two we need to be much much
better at working across
government uh in a collaborative way
and being able to move rapidly you don't
need 250 people
in a meeting if you're going to make
serious decisions uh
well one quick point if i may you in a
speech when you left and 2014
uh talked about uh the need for greater
diversity of skills
and a new approach to data and evolution
patricia hodgson who you know is a
a distinguished public servant published
a report this week which actually said
that
um the civil service really
needs to up its game in the use of
technology and digital and so on
uh do you detect that there's been any
response to your 2014 speech
in the seven years since in uh improving
the way we deal with
um delivery in civil service i think
we've got a lot more to do
i believe passionately in open
government i believe passionately in
having a more diverse
civil service not just in terms of
ethnicity and gender or those are
crucially important
but actually in terms of class as well
in terms of the range of skills and
and how much we value those technical
skills that hasn't
in the past been seen as the most
important thing to have
uh in in in being a civil servant
we now need to really recognize that
those deficiencies i talked about
have to be addressed if we're going to
be genuinely
world class we should probably in a way
stop saying the world class
until we've addressed them lord kerslake
thank you very much indeed